hello lovely people i'm alana and
welcome to my channel where today i am
catching up on two of the
e3 conferences that i missed and i
figured because i was going to watch
these
anyway that i could bring you guys along
for the ride um i guess these are more
like the leading into e3
end of may so we're gonna watch sonic
central which is about 12 minutes
apparently and then the dark pictures
anthology uh because i am a big fan of
supermassive who you might know probably
from until dawn
also obviously from the dark pictures
anthology yeah for any conferences that
i can't live stream i'll probably do
some of this for the ones i'm interested
in
so lots of e3 coverage incoming starting
with
sonic central let's go
i have no idea what there is here i've
not had any of this spoiled for me
i'm hoping there's a new sonic game
being announced but i guess we'll see
[Music]
cool
[Music]
welcome to our very first sonic central
in honor of sonic's anniversary
it's hard to believe that it's been 30
years since sonic first appeared
sonic is older than me beginning as a
video game character the old 16-bit
console era to today becoming an
entertainment icon across
movies animation video games comics and
much much more jim carrey
sonic and his friends continue to bring
joy to people around the world and that
means everything to us from sony consent
for a long time farm we say thank you
for being a part of sonic evolution over
the last 30 years
to our new friends we say welcome
in celebration of sonic 30th anniversary
we want to give you a sneak peek of a
lot of exciting content
that being worked on i hope there is
please get more movie stuff here but
there's a lot
more we will soon be sharing because i
actually found the movie to be quite fun
premiere of sonic central
and be sure to stick around till the end
so sit back
relax and enjoy the show i don't mind if
i do
thank you what a celebration without
music to celebrate the sounds of sonic
oh we are excited to host a virtual
symphony full of your favorite tracks
from throughout the years
that's neat i thought that they were
going to like give us a symphony now and
i was like you didn't expect that
symphony orchestra i love performances
seeing video game music wide
love it do it every opportunity i can
composer and dj tamuyatani
and others mark your calendars and look
forward to enjoying this performance on
sonic's birthday june 23rd
free that's cool that's really cool to
tune in to summer game fest for an
exclusive sneak peek
that's really neat i love that
guess who's competing at the olympic
games this year it's none other than the
blue one
i look
[Laughter]
oh my god
this is your chance to compete in this
year's olympics with your family and
friends
i don't know why i'm having this
reaction
oh my gosh i've had an asthma in this
hotel room for so long
something about somebody it's clearly
not sonic right it's just somebody
in a sonic suit next to humans
oh my god
god um you're terrifying you're [ __ ]
terrifying look how tall he looks
okay i'm sorry i'm really sorry this is
very cool it's cool content it just
looks really funny which i feel
positively about
my laughter is not a criticism
[Laughter]
and is available for pre-order today
oh my god next up is two pounds oh my
god
oh my god amazing i'm sorry i'm so sorry
the context i need to give is if i
didn't say it when i have asthma i find
things funnier because i'm not getting
enough oxygen to my brain with exclusive
sonic themed in-game items and
customization
have some fun characters
or add some swanky sonic decor to your
hospital
[Music]
repairs on july 30th and bring your
patients back to great health and
elegant
sonic style and speed
oh my god i'm so sorry
holy [ __ ] you might see more of this
chummy
sonic the fighters
stay tuned for more information on
future collaborations throughout the
year
[ __ ] i will i will watch those for the
rest of my life
[ __ ] that's funny oh jesus
okay sorry everybody i stopped so i
could grab my inhaler and compose myself
before we watch the next part of this i
didn't expect this to start this way
okay
oh that's how they call this
[Music]
the remaster
this looks really pretty
what was this game on wii
[Music]
nice cool guy
[Music]
we hate dragman that's exactly what we
want to do
[Music]
yeah very cool this looks good but it's
hard for me to remember exactly like
what it looked like i'd like to see side
by sides
it doesn't feel like it looked bad in my
head
um so i'd be interested to see how
different that update is speeding in the
storm
september 7th this year be sure to
pre-order online today to receive the
baby sonic keychain
and more in-game sonic movie content
stay tuned in 20 weeks to learn more
about sonic colors ultimate
very cool
and now let's hear from a very special
guest
hey hey everybody he does seem like a
wonderful human
sonic colors ultimate we are so excited
to announce
sonic colors rise of the wisps now
taking place in the world of sonic
colors this two-part animation is the
first of some short form animations
coming your way
that will feature full dialogue from the
sonic voice cast
in this you follow sonic and tales to
sweet mountain as they meet up with
their new friend the jade ghost wisp
to free all the captured wisps from the
evil dr eggman
and his robot henchmen and lucky you we
have a special treat that's a beautiful
voice
sorry it's roger craig smith my webcam
is covering that he is the voice of
sonic rose prevail
find out when sonic colors rise of the
wisps debuts
this summer we will see you guys soon
with so much more good stuff but for now
you know the drill we gotta go
nice he said the thing he said the thing
that sonic says
i wonder what audience this is aimed at
it's okay
[Music]
he's a cake buddy
[Music]
did they ever talk about why they chose
ben schwartz instead of
the original voice for the movie
it's a different vibe i suppose
i probably will not engage in that
necessarily because i don't watch a lot
of
supplementary content but it looks neat
and like the art style working on a new
compilation for next year that includes
sonic 1
oh cool sonic 3 and knuckles and sonic
cd
this is your chance to experience the
beginnings of sonic on the latest
platforms
now with added content and features i
wonder what they do about the aspect
ratio
for more information later in the year
probably stays
full three frequency taking sonic
deliveries and expanding
sonic mania and team sonic racing are
now available on amazon luna
also on june 1st sonic forces team sonic
racing and sonic mania are coming to
playstation now
starting in may and sonic dash sail into
a special pirate theme party
be among the first to unlock pirate
sonic and captain shadow
and win other great prizes by collecting
all four birthday themed items on the
track
this summer in sonic forces a very
special character will be dropping into
action
harness the power of this oh my blast
into battle as
sonic fly down the track at fantastic be
saying something and smash through your
opponent's attacks
in this invincible super form later this
year get ready to battle your friends in
some private races
this limited time event will allow you
to set up your own exclusive matches
with friends
enjoy the rush of sonic forces in this
fun party mode
this october prepare yourself for a
fright as the werehog bounds into sonic
forces and sonic dash this is a really
pleasant conference
i will say like there's a ton of this
that i'm not super interested in
um mobile games in general like racing
classic race as a classic character in a
classic
stuff i've already played in a lot of
cases um
all while listening to some brands but
this is really pleasant
now let's check in with the showrunners
of the recently announced animated
series
sonic pro see i have been interested to
learn more about this 22.
hi i'm joe kelly for man of action
entertainment and one of the show
runners on the upcoming netflix animated
series
sonic prime man of action is a writer's
collective
consisting of myself joe casey stephen t
siegel and duncan rulo
we created a couple of things you might
have heard of the ben 10 franchise for
cartoon network never out of it
the heroes and team of big hero 6 for
disney
and a bunch of other shows that we've
worked on over the years in anime it is
an impressive team i feel like the show
is probably going to be pretty good and
i am interested in inside working with
sega
and sonic on this project during sonic's
30th anniversary
and this is a dream project for us we've
been working really hard
to bring fans something that they've
never seen before in a sonic series
i would like to see it bring our
experience and passion for the brand
with us
on sonic because i'm expecting this to
be really funny and kind of hot phone
but a little bit more mature over the
course of 24 episodes
sonic will be thrust into a high-speed
adventure through the strange and
mysterious shatterers
it's up to sonic to save the universe
and along the way
experience moments of self-discovery and
redemption
sonic prime is set to premiere worldwide
in 2022.
we look forward to taking this journey
with you and sharing more information
with you
at a later date things like this
thanks again it's so cute
um again a tv show i don't know
necessarily if i watch it but i did want
to see more of it i am curious
what it looks like it is hard to sell me
on a tv show but i am i have been
interested in the development of that
for sure
it's a great team straight from sonic 2
with the giant eggman robot playset from
jack specific how big is that that
doesn't look that big fans dialed into
hip hop
comes the sonic the hedgehog 30th
anniversary jewelry collaboration with
king ice
you can also revisit 30 years of sonic
games with the comprehensive 30th
anniversary in cyclo speedia and dark
horse
nice that's really nice we have an
exclusive collection of coins in silver
and gold from app max
head to the official sonic 30th
anniversary site for more information on
all of our commemorative products
well there you have it as you can see
we've been working hard behind the
scenes to prepare great things for you
there will be a lot of announcements
throughout the year so be sure to follow
us on official social channels
linked in the video description below so
thank you for celebrating with us and
being there every step of the way
here's to the next 30 years of signing
hold on i don't think we are done yet
i have one more thing i'd like to show
the fan all right
let's see it
[Music]
that's what i'm here for
or movie info you take that too
just look like a new game to me
cool very exciting
i think that's probably the end yeah so
a kind of awkward conference from the
top there i feel like um
some of their presenter choices were a
little bit awkward seeing people reading
on screens kind of thing
new game stuff is really exciting it
feels like it's it's jew
so that's awesome i wish we had seen a
little bit more of course but maybe
they'll tell us more
throughout the year but yeah i'm sure
the hardcore sonic fans of which i know
there are many
got a little bit more out of this um
even though it was still really fun
so the next one is we are watching the
dark pictures anthology info
it's gonna be here
that was a good timing 18. so this is
dark pictures anthology house of ashes
first look
and gameplay reveal
hey there i'm will doyle game director
of supermassive games here in the uk
today i'd like to talk to you about
house of ashes the third game in the
dark pictures anthology
normally in the run-up to launch we'd be
getting the game into your hands at
shows and game events around the world
unfortunately how i first played until
dawn possible with the world as it is
right now
so today i'd like to do the next best
thing and take you through some of the
game myself
so that you can get a sense of how this
actually is might be the next game i
play through on the channel later this
year i might do that the dark picture's
unfolding trying to keep those spooky
games so
always let's do house of ashes to
frighten you to challenge you
and to surprise you with households i
have played the first two parts i think
you're in for a real treat
chapters but if you're new to the
anthology let me tell you a little bit
about how it works
you'll find that house of ashes is a
great place to jump on board
the dark picture's anthology is a series
of standalone
narrative horror games where the fates
of the five characters that you play are
entirely in your hands and that's true
they can also
make consequences are real story
branches out and ultimately
determines the endings that they receive
everyone can live
everyone can die but the story never
stops
the character dies there's no reset to
go back
each game in the anthology has multiple
endings because we know that after that
we're looking at the times to discover
all of the possibilities
all of our games also have some basis in
a real world fact or legend our first
game
had the legend of the oran medan then
little hope explored salem
and the andover witch trials house of
ashes explores a new mystery
one that is older than anything we've
done i don't know very much about this
what is this place the original teaser
trailer for house of ashes
unlocked when you finish little hope and
is now available online
so what do we know so far we know it's
set in the middle east
and it deals with a military unit
running into trouble deep underground
i feel like that's all i know we saw our
star character played by ashley tisdale
wading through a river of blood and
bones holding a human thigh bone for a
torch
and she's clearly not alone down there
there are monsters
in the dark so how did you get there
and what kind of monsters is what i want
to know is set back in 2003
at a close of hostilities in the iraq
war hunting for weapons of mass
destruction
a team comprising u.s special forces air
force and cia
is sent on a mission to unearth an
underground chemical weapons depot
that's been picked up on satellite
arriving on the scene
they come under attack by hold out iraqi
forces
and during the firefight the earthquake
pitches both sides into the ground below
where they discover a vast underground
temple i love the way they do faces
the ancient kingdom of akkad the
supermassive faces look good
it's home to a very real threat a nest
of monsters
that hungry for blood our heroes went
looking for weapons of mass destruction
but they uncovered something far far
worse something very very old
the elderly much like a weapon silo to
me everybody's least favorite thing
mesopotamia
the historic land includes what is now
iraq was the cradle of civilization its
written records date back almost 6 000
years the temple that dwells at the
heart of our game
was built by a real world historical
figure the self-proclaimed
god king of the acadian empire naram sin
who reigned around it's gonna be in the
game 250 all right bc
cool naram sin is said to have upset the
gods
and brought a curse down on his people
by ransacking a temple belonging to
enlil
the god of earth wind and storms the
gods brought war famine and plague on
his kingdom
in our story naram sin builds this huge
temple
as a peace offering to the gods to lift
the curse
but his pleas fall on death ears akkad
falls and naram sin's temple is buried
under the desert sands
it looks like a really big environment
millennia later
especially these people there's a way
out for us they largely found really
claustrophobic i don't give away too
much of a story
in a good way intense this looks like a
bigger environment then
two separate groups for sure a little
hope had a little more openness
to survive they must forge an alliance
with their enemies from the surface
i think it's just you and me no that's
interesting they'll unravel the
mysteries of this ancient
temple the enemy of my enemy is my
friend
our first traitor his face didn't like
that good ashley tisdale's sorry
cia officer rachel king did you see
sergeant k
alongside two of the marines that you
can play in the game jason colchek
we're on god's greener than we landed
and nick k
is this place in our latest we see
rachel exploring underground with her
husband
colonel eric king looks old old
it's ancient but that's
uniform later we meet the fifth playable
character from our game
iraqi officer saleem offman as he
encounters something
deadly and horrific exciting in the
shadows
it's pazuzu
kazuzu
when creating our dark pictures
the wealth of horror gameplay available
house of ashes takes some inspiration
from the works of h.p lovecraft
in particular the novel at the mountains
of madness
i'm a very big fan of lovecrafting and
horror house of ashes is an exploration
horror
a group of experts on a critical mission
in a remote location
cut off from any backup facing an
inhuman
enemy threat who's there it's also a
story about loyalty
duty and trust characters are always at
the heart of our stories
and when faced with overwhelming odds
each character in house of ashes must
decide whether to save their own hide
or set aside their personal rivalries
and prejudices that's true technically
you get to decide though
if we fight together we may get through
this
it's a damn shot better than the
alternative yeah it seems like they're
all very
different you'll face really difficult
dilemmas around survival and
collaboration
what risks will you take to ensure
nobody gets left behind
and when all hell sometimes you want
some of them to die there's always one
that you don't like
or is it just look after number one show
some mercy please
of course it wouldn't be a dark pictures
game without some terrible danger
waiting to perform our protagonists and
in house of ashes
the threat is very real the creatures in
house of ashes
are some of the most complicated we've
ever made but through hand animation and
motion capture we've created a monster
wow
it's very believable very threatening
that's so cool to look at
yes and there's a whole nest of them
down there waiting for you they're close
fired up you're crazy our environments
are often claustrophobic and enclosed
it's true regularly open out into vast
magnificent spaces
we want you to feel exposed vulnerable
and threatened i like the settings
meaning you're being
watched at all times by creatures you
know nothing about
it'll feel a little bit like the caves
in until dawn probably
at the mineshaft place of majesty and
mystery
that is laying undisturbed for millennia
sergeant k
pull yourself together eyes wide
i saw something if you've played
previous dark pictures games you'll get
an instant feel for the game mechanics
you need to get out of here
yeah i wonder if there are any new
mechanics we're always looking to
improve our games
and we're always grateful for the
comments that we've received from you
our community
which have helped us to focus on the
areas that matter most to you
in house of ashes you'll see many
improvements to the way the game handles
fixed cameras have been entirely
replaced with 360 degree
player control camera awesome which
makes exploration much more important
and that's gonna be great for this
environment too that's great inclusion
and probably makes things a little bit
scarier using the flashlight lets you
sweep the dark for secrets
and uncover new parts i like that but
slows you down a little
you'll come to rely on it as you delve
into some of the darker sections of the
catcoons
also adding difficulty settings to the
game so you can tailor the game to the
experience you're looking for
easy medium or no holds bar that's gonna
our fan feedback around qtes shows that
you're yeah
vary the qt's well others think they're
too easy
i should go easy on those because that's
an issue i have with these games pcs
lets you tailor the speed of the qtes to
your own skill set
i can't button match because i have
tendonitis in my wrist for this title to
include enhanced version they do
sometimes require you to
on those formats you'll see a marked
improvement in overall graphical
hell yeah you weren't playing for that
correct mom let's get to work
as with man house of ashes features four
main modes
shared story which allows you to play
through the whole game online with a
friend
it's really fun i played it with uh john
smith it's up to five players in the
same room
also very funny two separate single
player parts the main theatrical cut
and the curator's cut which is available
as a pre-order bonus
on curator's cut you get to experience
some story from the perspective of
different characters
even see scenes that you wouldn't
normally see in the theatrical time
so hopefully you've enjoyed hearing me
talk about the game yeah now it's time
to show you some of it in action
yeah i'd like to show you one of the
scenes that marks the start of things
getting much much more worse for our
team
as if getting shot at and falling
through the ground wasn't bad enough
i like him the scene starts our
characters are pitched into the depths
after an earthquake
they've been splitting still looks
cinematic though where's the gameplay at
i know where they are
in the theatrical cut our playable
character here is nick
one of the fourth recon marines sent to
search for wmds
in the curator's cut you play as his
buddy jason
finding himself underground nick starts
to navigate his way through the tunnels
looking for his comrades
as he works his way towards james it
looks good he soon finds out that
it's probably a game of play on ps5
maybe a q a i could play it on pc jason
also finds himself well i don't know
anything
from the group as the story plays out
he's presented with different choices
whatever will make it look prettier
does he act large and in charge keep
discipline or does he pay attention to
what his friend is saying
no matter how crazy it may sound you
pull your [ __ ] together right
now before you get us both killed so i
hope you've enjoyed this short video on
house of ashes
and i look forward to getting your hands
on it please check out our channels for
more information look after yourselves
thank you
and keep both feet on the ground because
you never know when it's going to fall
out from underneath you
i don't like that okay
now we got gameplay satellite sweeps of
the war zone have uncovered what appears
to be an underground
storage facility but i strongly suspect
to make myself a little bit smaller
things are hidden so we need to move
fast
hold the gameplay reveal there you go
this rate's a bust these people are not
the enemy they're just shepherds
[Music]
i assume that this would have a lot less
cuts for some reason
this gameplay reveal well maybe it's
just leading into it is what it's doing
that was a mouth i think who knew okay
here we go
i think i'll just go theatrical cut
probably
oh man good to have some replayability
again
this is mailman two one actual all team
sound off over
ah [ __ ]
the rest of the squad must be around
here somewhere hmm
jason yeah it makes it seem like a very
different
jason game i'm close mate
oh that is dark oh my
yeah i actually feel like i should do a
let's play of this i'll be real scared
but don't sound too promising
want to be clickers
it's very pretty down there
i get that there are spooky monsters but
i feel like you'd be like whoa cool let
me take my phone and take some pictures
it looks great
that you nick
well ain't that something
we're on god's greener than we landed
hmm we need to get back topside regroup
with the rest of the squad and signal
for medivac
this place ain't no weapon silo but it
sure is crawling with iraqis
i don't know if that's what it is mate
sergeant k pull yourself together
eyes wide
i saw something what do you mean shove
something
i mean it was a human
in a tunnel
should have never gotten up that hilo
don't do this nick not now i need you to
keep it together just a while longer
something's not right i know you can
feel it only thing i'm feeling is that i
got my work cut out with you
hmm
it is a really big part of these games
for anyone who's not been familiar is
like
how the characters interact with each
other what they say what their
relationships are like
uh while in a horror setting gosh i
flunked history at school
i like it though it uh really is like
playing a horror movie that's what they
feel like
um often like a cheesy horror movie too
which makes the movie night mode
really fun tell me you don't feel it
what nick
that's part of what i think would
probably make it a fun game to to play
through one uh
on youtube
[Music]
who knew it's like the totems
they let you see potential outcomes
what was that reflection
i'm gonna need some more muscle i'm
skipping jim again
i feel attacked
[Music]
seems convenient if anything jesus i'm
trying will you stop squirming around
oh it's bad he's bleeding out we have to
cut him down right now
little tat buddy he's bleeding out
oh those have cut him up
not as ideal as i thought turns out
[Music]
it is a bad idea you're not supposed to
say that to people who are dying it
makes them more likely to go into shock
and die ugh
oh no what the [ __ ]
just happened
not ideal worries
what happened
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
sound design is fantastic
let's give it to him straight not gonna
lie man it's pretty
bad shut up hold
[Music]
for the on because the camera's over it
does say theatrical cut on the left
if it's on the left and it's covered it
says theatrical cut
[Music]
oh my
[Applause]
you trying to suffocate a guy
more french kicked in no it's morphine
okay
that makes sense
yeah it looks super cool um i really
like
what they've been doing with these i
really like supermassive in general
i don't feel like watching this like it
gave me more context to what it was
going to be and i was really curious
after the teaser trailer initially
released or after i saw it rather um of
what the setting was going to be
so never released it yet seems like
it'll be later in the year
but yeah that's uh that's something i'm
gonna play anyway so
definitely down with that um some cool
stuff here i liked both presentations i
feel like everyone has kind of gotten
better at them they're definitely fun to
watch
it's always exciting to see what
incredibly creative and talented people
talented people are working on around
the world too so
yeah thank you all for joining me for
these uh i will see you guys next time